hello everyone and welcome to round one
of the 1972 match of the century between
bodies vasilyevitch Spassky and the
Robert James Fisher although it could
have easily been the 1972 match of the
century in Belgrade and regularly but
we're gonna talk about that a bit more
after we cover some of the basics so if
you remember and if you've been enjoying
the Fisher series so far we've covered
the palma de mallorca inter zonal
tournament and if you remember Fischer
didn't even qualify for the palm of
America inter-zonal tournament because
he didn't play the US championship that
was kind of a requirement at the qualify
for the intros onal tournament but he
pretty much crushed the field there then
he continued to the candidates matches
where he well let's say destroyed marked
a man of bent Larsen and former world
champion Tigran Petrosian two of the two
of the previous ones were the result of
6 to 0 and then Tigran Petrosian with a
result of 6 and a half to 2 and a half
which which qualified him gave him this
opportunity to challenge boris Vasily
which Spassky for the title now Fischer
and Spassky played five games before
their encounter in Reykjavik and from
those five games Fischer didn't win a
single one as Pascal won three and the
two of the games were drawn but before
the match in Reykjavik could even happen
a lot of conditions would have to be met
by both sides
for example immediately after this match
with Petrosyan was over in bonus iris
the venue of the match of the century
had to be decided where will the match
be played and Fischer said that he
didn't really enjoy the way Soviets
treated this whole situation for example
after a fish was matched with Dignam
Petrosyan in in the Russian newspapers
and they didn't really cover this news
that greatly for example there was like
this little article about Fischer's a
great victory over Tigran Petrosian and
then there was this
for example local tournament in Russia
that that was given the headline but if
for example Tigran Petrosian had won his
match against Fischer then it would be
the
line in all the newspapers and
officially had a lot of similar stories
for example he said that if he was to
play an international tournament and he
required the tournament organisers to
pay Fischer for example $1,000 or or
even two thousand dollars that the
Soviets would send their strong
grandmasters to play there for free so
Fischer wouldn't get any any media
presence and the list of course goes on
so now that they had to decide where to
play the match it was a very interesting
the Soviets first out of the 12 possible
options because 12 organizers applied
the Soviets agreed to the four of them
as even worth considering in order of
likelihood to happen it was a number one
Reykjavik number two Amsterdam number
three Dortmund and the number four Paris
and Fischer didn't really like those
four options well first of all a Fischer
also had to keep an eye on the prize
fund the prize fund in Reykjavik was a
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
and Fischer would much prefer the prize
fund in Belgrade which was something
like a hundred and fifty something I
believe one hundred and fifty six
thousand dollars so although Fischer
would prefer to play the match of the
century in for example Belgrade or
Sarajevo or even when Osiris
I think Fischer the preferred playing in
Buenos Aires the most but they simply
didn't offer enough money for the prize
fund so then and there's also this other
thing Fischer did not want to agree to
any of the terms Spassky and the Soviets
offered for example he refused all of
the four cities the Soviets offered not
so much just because of the prize fund
but he also didn't want to concede to
any terms by the Soviets and he also
said that the Soviets play way worse
when they are on the other side of the
Atlantic so of course he wanted Spassky
to come to him and the spot he said that
all of the matches you know during the
candidates matches were played pretty
much where Fischer wanted them to be
played so he didn't wanna
be fooled by that so that being said
they couldn't really agree where the
match of the century will be played so
the president of video dr. max you've a
decided that it will be played the first
half of the match will be played in
Belgrade so 12 games in Belgrade and
then the other 12 games or or less if
you know the match perhaps will not last
for 24 games will be played in Reykjavik
and Fischer didn't really enjoy this
decision by bifida president and Spassky
didn't like it either and Spassky
already felt cheated because he said
okay I mean I'm the world champion and
now you give Fischer his terms his 12
games in Belgrade but the match might
not last 24 games so he will get more
games in Belgrade than I will get in
breakaway for example but as poss he
didn't disagree with the decision but on
the other hand the Fischer did Fischer
said that this was a no-go and that he
does not agree to play under such terms
you know moving from here to there it's
just not fitting for such a match but
then as Feder president dr. Hoover could
not come to a decision how to solve this
he gave Fischer an ultimatum
he taught Fischer that either he will
play first half in Belgrade second half
in Reykjavik or that the match is off
and that there will be another match
World Championship match that will be
the Boris Spassky versus Tigran
Petrosian that will be played in Moscow
so here Fischer didn't really have any
choice he had to agree to these terms
and he did agree to these terms but then
after you know other arrangements were
to be made
Fischer started making a lot of a lot of
different complaints for example he he
wanted the different chairs to be played
you know for them to be seated in during
the match at different lighting
different contrast of the pieces and the
board different everything but most of
all he demanded more money such one such
example is he demanded that the players
get 30% of the gate money and none of
the organizers would would comply to
those rules as it's simply too much
money and the organizers do organize it
these events I mean they do like the
chest but mostly they do it for the
money and Fisher said I mean if clay can
you know ask for such terms of why
couldn't I why it's just so different
than boxing talking about the the match
between Muhammad Ali and of course
organizers in Belgrade could not comply
to this and they decided to back out so
now only Reykjavik was left and Fischer
said that he still does not agree to
those terms but Russian Chess Federation
and Spassky said that you know the the
the terms have been agreed upon and that
the match will be held in Reykjavik
official wants to play Fischer will come
to Reykjavik and so it was already
almost time to play there were it was
like one day and when the match should
start at the opening ceremony started
the Fischer of course was not on the
opening ceremony in Reykjavik only
Spassky was there Fischer was still in
New York and here there was a bit of a
controversial decision by Feder
president maxilla he decided to postpone
the beginning of the match by two days
so he took it upon himself to give
Fischer more more time to reconsider and
to come play this match of the century
and that wouldn't really impress Fischer
all that much but it was actually it was
actually British just promoter Jim
Slater you have a quote above the board
by mr. Jim Slater if money is the
question here it is and now come out and
play you chicken this is what he sets
the Fischer and on top of the 125,000
dollars price fund that the organizers
in Reykjavik offered mr. Jim Slater also
offered the 50,000 pounds which is
something like another $125,000 so he
doubled the prize fund and told Fischer
if it's money you want here's the money
you know go play Spassky you chicken and
it also took of course phone phone call
from the former Secretary of State mr.
Henry Kissinger and although I don't
knowing Fischer and not knowing him
personally but reading a lot about
Fischer I don't think he would be that
impress
from getting a call from a secretary of
state as a Fisher often said that he
does not represent the United States he
represents Bobby Fischer he represents
himself but you know in the previous
tournaments in Fischer's previous
attempts to you know conquer the chess
Olympus he didn't really get all that
much backup from the United States but
here when they heard about Fischer
winning in Buenos Aires Agustin
petrosyan he even received a letter from
President Nixon saying that the United
States are backing him up with anything
he needs so it kind of pretty much all
worked out
as poss given said that he didn't
actually think the match would happen
but he did play his part in trying to
make the match actually happen so
Fischer finally went to Reykjavik he
went to Iceland and when when he got
there the match was still not being
played the match was again postponed
because now
Spassky insisted that Fischer should
publicly apologize to him for breaking
fides rules and you know being late for
the match for so long but seemingly oh
you know how things worked out and how
Fischer managed to get all this money
not the gate prize money but the money
from mr. Jim Slater which is basically
doubling the prize fund really worked
out for him as he did publicly
apologized to Boris Spassky on American
television and this was the cause of the
mat-su being postponed for one more day
so now everything is set in motion the
match was late for some 11 days I
believe
Spassky is now in the playing hall and
you know he Fischer still isn't there
and Spassky looks around he's not there
the clocks have been started Spassky
plays d4 and Fischer still is nowhere to
be found
as Pascal was also a big a big E for man
for example in his match against Tigran
Petrosian he did play a lot of e4 and
you know in games throughout he enjoyed
e4 very much but he thought against his
American opponent d4 was definitely the
way to go and some as
you know people reported it nine minutes
have passed their Fisher comes to the
stage sits at the Board agreed Spassky
and he replies with Knight to f6 which
is what Fischer usual usually replies to
when faced with the d4 and okay
the game starts we have c4 e6 and Knight
to f3 Spassky for now avoids the news of
Indian and offers Fischer the
opportunity to go for the Queen's Indian
defense but Fischer ignores this and of
course transposed into the Queens gambit
declined
we have Knight to c3 by Spassky and
Bishop to b4 now again there might be an
Enzo Indian on the board and in fact
what he does play III and it goes into
this very timid line of the nimzo-indian
defense but but by this move order he
avoids a lot of very sharp lines that
would be it would have been available
for black on the other hand instead of
this Bishop to b4 move Fischer usually
did enjoy to play c5 but we've already
seen c5 in spassky's game against Icahn
on petrosyan where he won a very nice
game in game 5 in his championship match
against Tigran Petrosian so Bishop to b4
we have III avoiding all the scary lines
we have castles by Fischer and now
Bishop to d3 and ok chris renaud was for
c5 and we have the castles and now comes
Knight to c6 we have a three attacking
the bishop and here some of the this is
a well known position in the
nimzo-indian defense moves like Bishop
captures on c3 or seek after son before
are quite neutral responses here but
here Fischer actually goes for Bishop to
a5 and here this is the first moment in
the game where Spassky doesn't reply
automatically here as passkey has to
think about his reply so he was not
ready for this Bishop play 5 move so it
seems that Fischer definitely out
prepared Spassky and here after Bishop
to a5 we have Knight to e2 after some
consideration Spassky plays this nice to
e2 and here it was clear
not the Spassky at the time he played
this move but to those
whose job was to prepare Spassky Knights
the e2 is a move Spassky already played
14 years ago against nikola grandmaster
nikolai Kroger's grandmaster nikolai
Kroger's is one of the two grandmasters
that served as Spassky ii during the
champion match with Fischer first one
being Grandmaster F in Geller and this
move like I said was already played and
Fischer knew this because Fischer had
this red book of 355 spassky's games
that he probably knew by heart and in
this book also this game against nikolai
Chronos was present there in this game
92 was played and here we have d
captures on c4 d captures on c4 ok he
captures on c4 and we have Bishop
captures on c4 rush up to b6 now
defending the c5 pawn and now D captures
on c5 the same as in the game with
Nikolai Kroger's but in that game Bishop
captures on c5 was played here a Fischer
takes a different approach Queen
captures Queen so immediately exchanging
Queens rook captures on d1 and now
Bishop captures on c5 so it's only moved
12 but Fisher already got the Queens of
the board and the two points on on the
Queen side for each players and four
pawns on the Kings side the material is
completely equal so a pleasant position
to have for black against a world
champion already and move 12 B for
attacking for special Bishop goes back
to e7 and now Bishop to b2 and here
Bishop to d7 a very nice move by Fischer
the the idea is that at some point this
night will move and then Fischer will
use this special play for a move to get
a temple on this rook and develop all of
his pieces here Bishop captures on f6
isn't all that impressive because Bishop
captures and after rook captures on d7
rook captures Bishop captures rook on a1
so black would of course be better here
so here we have rook a to C 1 and now
rook F to D 892 d4 Knight captures
Knight captures and now comes the bishop
to a for the move we discussed that
allows Fischer
to activate his pieces Bishop to b3 by
Spassky a very nice move by Spassky that
you have to see that Bishop captures and
b3 was played in the game but rook
captures and e4 doesn't really do
anything for black because of course you
will ignore the rook you will not
capture the rook and a lot of Bishop
captures Bishop but you will play Bishop
captures Bishop immediately and then
after rook captures we have rook out for
somebody one and now rook to d8 rook
captures rook captures and after white
brings back the bishop you have the
material is equal on the board but
everyone would prefer the bishop will
bear against the the bishop and denied
here
so after Bishop to b3 we have Bishop
captures Knight captures and the now
rook captures on d1 rook after sandy won
and now rook the c8 and here our Fischer
says that his his rook and the C file is
a more impressive than spassky's rook on
the D file because Fischer here controls
the D scores and also the knight
controls the d7 so there's no way for
spot Spassky to ever infiltrate
Fischer's position here whereas spots
can only control c1 and c3 not so much
c2 but still it's not so easy to take
advantage of this in any way here King
to f1 is played you don't really achieve
anything with Bishop captures on f6 you
do remove the defender of the d7 square
but then if you go for this
for example rook c3 after rook captures
of course you cannot capture tonight
immediately due to the main threats on
the back rank but then after h5 and
white decides to move the rook you move
the sorry denied you move the knight for
the back and only then do you recapture
the pawn material is equal but perhaps
the outside passed pawn will well it's
not passed just yet but the outside pawn
perhaps will be a bit more meaningful
and it is a night against a bishop
against tonight so simply improving the
position of the King King to f1 Fischer
does the same King to f8 and it the idea
is similar a Fischer can't even fall
trait immediately we are up to c2
because now Bishop captures and now
after G captures you get this rook to d7
again with with some threat
here so Fisher improves the position of
the skin came to a faith we have King to
eat two spots improves the position of
the King even further and now Knight to
e4 already if white is you know not not
so careful for example if something like
eight for a silly move is played then
rook to c2 this is the threat this would
win the game it's check you're gonna
lose the bishop and if you try to attack
the knight then even f5 with ideas of
capturing an f2 with checkmate are
possible so after Knight to e4 rope to
see one simply countering Fischer's rook
on the C file and now we have rope
captures on c1 Bishop captures on c1 and
now f6 we have knife to a5 and now
Knight to d6 Knight to d6 is a much
neater move you you don't want to push
your pawns once you push up on you can
never undo it and here white would
simply use this as an opportunity to
further attack your pawns for example a
six-night to b8 now we further attack
the pawn a 5 now you can even further
attack it for example captures capture
some Knight to c6 and now there's a
really no way to protect it you have to
push it to a light square now that it's
in a light square Bishop can no longer
protect it and the white would after
kicking away the knight would easily
pick up this pawn so after Knight to a5
we have nice the d6 guarding the pawn
and then out comes King to d3 Bishop to
d8
forcing the knight back nice to see for
a c4 and the now Bishop the c7 we have a
bishop cap a knight captures the Bishop
captures and now b6 a great move as
Fischer has a dark square Bishop you
don't want your pawns on dark squares at
some points possible even push a 4 and
connect the pawns on light squares under
on the Queen side and this is the
critical moment in the game and the most
critical moment in any game of any World
Chess Championship that was ever played
this is unimaginable this is probably
the worst the worst blunder Fischer made
in his entire career here you can pretty
much sense that the position is
completely wrong but here after not so
much consideration
I mean for playing such a move you would
have to calculate it perfectly but
Fisher just played Bishop captures on h2
and when everyone saw this because it's
very interesting I forget to me I forgot
to mention this because there are so
many things about you you could talk
about here about this match but the last
10 World Chess Championship matches were
actually played in Moscow as all of the
contenders were Soviet chess players and
here when for the first time you have
someone else contending for the title
this time an American Bobby Fischer
you know Reykjavik doesn't have any
experience organizing such matches so
they pretty much took everything from
the Soviets
but instead of the big demonstration
boards they have closed a closed-circuit
television so they had a lot of monitors
placed everywhere and people in the back
even had headphones where they could
listen to some commentary and when this
was played a couple of thousands
thousand people were like completely
baffled and grandmasters who were
watching this no one knew what was
happening when favor captured this I
mean of course every every child knows
that you don't capture this because g3
traps the bishop
but when Fischer plays it in a World
Chess Championship match then it's like
you you do kind of have to question
everything you know about chess is this
winning for black is this way why would
Fischer do this in a completely drawn
position so it didn't take Spassky all
that much time to reply he simply played
g3 which is what everyone would played
and now everyone was ok what now and ok
Fischer continued h5 we have King to e2
@ h4 King to f3 and now after king came
to f3
they say that Fischer saw this and
realized that perhaps he'd he he might
have missed something
ah here we have a nice photo of at this
moment it's not from this moment might
not even be from this game the the
position on the board does somewhat
seemed like position that would be
similar from a later position but
irregardless is just something to get
you in the mood you know completely
disregard the position on the board but
yeah here a Fisher figured out that he
probably missed something so okay King
to e7 was played we have King to e7 and
now King to g2 as the bishop is trapped
this is this is well known H characters
on g3 the way we have F captures on g3
Bishop captures King captures and now
King to d6 so our two pawns compensation
enough for spassky's extra piece a for
this is definitely the best idea
connecting his pawns and also preparing
the bishop to a3 if you played something
like king to have three to start
improving the position of your king then
after King to c5 threatening to capture
this it's white black would have at
least a drone endgame because now you
can start grabbing pawns on the Queen
side so after King 36 a4 Spassky goes
for the best idea we have King to d5 and
now Bishop to a3 again the best move
simply controlling the dark squares on
the Queen side again if you tried
something like instead of Bishop to e3
King to f3 again then King to c4 would
have been enough for black for example
Bishop to e3 but now b6 Bishop goes back
now comes g6 King goes to B for now
comes King to b b3 Bishop to e7
attacking f6 now comes King characters
on a for Bishop CalPERS on f6 and now
King captures and b5 and now you have to
connect to past months on the Queen side
it's not white can't really do all that
much would would one pawn king e5 simply
king c4 King characters now comes King
d3 attacking the pawn bishop before
defending and now King to before the
king is on a light Square and now
there's nothing that can pull this thing
off of his light square and now after
black simply pushes all of his pawns at
some point white bishop will have to
move from from the pond and then King
captures and now the game is a draw so
after King d5 Bishop to a three
strongest replied by Spassky we
King to e4 and now Bishop to c5 we have
a six and now b6 as poss he has to keep
as many points on the board as possible
if he wants to allow for winning chances
later f5 we have came to h4 the correct
idea and here fresh replace f4 and
everyone agreed that after this move all
of the drawing chances were gone because
now the two passed pawns Fischer will
have and the King side will simply not
be all that impressive
so okay he captures on f4 we have King
captures on f4 and here King to h5
forgot to mention after this f4 move as
possibly decided to take the game into
adjournment
he decided to seal his for the first
move I was a pretty obvious which his
41st move will be so it wasn't like a
surprise or anything but he had to waste
25 minutes and on the clock of his own
time at steal the move here and continue
the game tomorrow during adjournment but
you know it was well worth it because
better do it now and then find a winning
game at home so here the game was
adjourned it was continued tomorrow and
of course this was played but that was
not that much of a surprise King
captures an f4 and now King to h5 this
is the move of course they had to find
this is the winning idea the King now
has to sorry about that the King has to
travel all this way and start grabbing
all of these pawns on the Queen side and
the dark square Bishop will simply move
back and forth and keep an eye on the b6
pawn because the b6 pawn is the winning
point in this game or will be king - f5
Fischer doesn't allow Spassky to enter
the the Queen side Bishop to e3 and the
now King to e4 attacking the bishop
bishop comes to f2 now come scheme to f5
and Bishop to h4 now and now the black
king is in choose one you have to move
you have to move at least one point if
you move the King for example King b5
then you allow Spassky scheme to start
approaching the b7 pawn so here you're
really without
any options 'if i was played and okay
now comes the Bishop to g5 we have E 4
and now Bishop to e3 again with the idea
of putting black in in troops Wang so
you have to move the king and now comes
came to G for the White King is out of
his prison King to e5 na komm scheme to
g5 and now King to d5 King to f5 is
played King - if official pushes a5
Bishop to F - and now g5 Fischer gives
up one more point at least displace the
White King for a moment King captures
and now he goes for the Queen side pawns
but the problem is you can never capture
the b6 pawn King to f5 was played now
comes King 2b for King capture Sonny for
King to a for capturing a pawn we have
pink the d5 we have kicked the b5 and
hereafter Spassky played King to d6 it
was in this position that Bobby Fischer
resigned the game unmoved 56 why did he
resign well whatever he does he can
never capture the b6 pawn and Spassky
will simply capture to be 7 point for
example he can start pushing his own
passport as possibly will simply keep an
eye on it with the bishop after the
bishop is attacked you will simply move
it
and when Fischer starts pushing his past
pawn it will simply attack the b7 pawn
capture the pawn move the King and then
Queen the b-pawn while black can never
Queen D a pawn
so after King to d6 after all this drama
and you know it took months of months of
preparing in the psychological warfare
to even get this match started and it
took a lot of people to even make it
happen from her from fear the president
makes you wait - as you as you've heard
Henry Kissinger Jim Slater here who
offered the money like everyone everyone
and not the greatest start to the match
by Bobby Fischer it was a it's hard to
imagine why would you do such a move I
mean you have the black pieces you've
pretty much came on top for you you
you've shown you've came more prepared
than the world champion you already had
a completely drawn position on the board
by move 12 you could have easily drawn
it and then they
game you have the white pieces but
official decided to grab the h2 pawn and
lose the game so very very very
interesting turn of events and I'm sure
there are there's so much you can say
about this match like I've already read
two books and one reading the third book
about this match and in every book there
are more interesting informations
there's more interesting information on
and the entire match so I do recommend
to everyone to check out any book on
this match I'm sure you'll enjoy it
there's just no way to say everything
about it in one video but if I've missed
anything like really important there are
still more games to come in this match
so we're gonna cover that as well so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Fred Ackerman
Jason Bertram Robert Allison Carl Martin
and joshua cooper for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon with
another game from the Fischer Spassky
series from the whole Bobby Fischer
story and perhaps the bottom just
tolling beard is running tomorrow we'll
see how things go there so thank you all
and I'll see you soon